Jessa beaver joined James Corden a
carpool karaoke last night on The Late
Late Show and his appearance was the
first since 2015 so the two had a lot of
catching up to do
yeah they sure did and Corden wanted to
know why Justin challenged Tom Cruise to
a fight in the Octagon last June
remember when he tweeted that oh good
times
all right so let's just say the two got
into a rather heated argument over who
would win in that fight the beads for
Tom I don't know this is Ben how is
being stupid to be it's not stupid but
then people were like yeah I want to see
this happen and I was like you know what
that could actually be funny much fun
for you hey I gotta say I think if me
and you have a fight you win I think if
you and Tom Cruise have a fight Mike Tom
every day of the week I'll try not to
let my ego get in the way but there's
absolutely no there's absolutely no way
he's not the guy you see in Jerry's he's
not shape phenomenal shape doesn't mean
see I start to get frustrated because
like you're really boiling they out man
be a good thing work your way up to Tom
Cruise to me
did you like Zach Braff no Tom Cruise I
think by the characters that he's
playing I'm mesmerized by the movies the
mission is impossible my mind control is
I'm Cree I'm different
listen I'm the corner MacGregor of
entertainment okay I have had lots of
opinions over the years about Justin
Bieber for the times that I've sat
across from him and the times that I've
just observed
I like this Justin Bieber this one right
now this one right now I think it's
gonna be as happy no I don't actually
know and I don't actually think that he
is happy I think that I think that
happiness is is a far distant goal I
think that he is content and I think
that he is more comfortable in his skin
yeah I think that he's out of the
shadows that he was in for for so long
but I think that happiness is probably
something that he's working toward still
but no I like this I like Justin I like
him being a troll and I know called out
for his tweet and instead of just
shutting it down he just turns into this
like it he just like double down on the
whole troll I like it and I like that
he's you know engaging in the idea that
you know he might want to fight Tom
Cruise even though the whole thing is
insane and this is a giant goof yeah I
like this Justin Bieber I do too okay so
Nelson saying Tom Cruise had not met
with funnel no when in essence he has a
point
he probably I know he does a lot of his
own stunts and but but you know he's you
know maybe they're like they're not like
super giant men maybe they write be able
to go at each other I just think that
it's willing who's
when you put a Tom Cruise like I'm
trying to get serious when you put Tom
Cruise in any sort of situation against
somebody like Justin Bieber it's only a
matter of who's going to be willing to
go farther and I think that Tom Cruise
is obsessive enough he would kill Justin
Bieber like I just think that that's the
way that it goes everything the man does
is he obsesses over it and does what no
other person would ever do put
themselves in that position as somebody
who's extremely rich and famous and
privileged I think that he would kill
Justin Bieber actually murdered okay
maaske is saying all tom has to do is
look at him and Tom would win start
saying yeah Humphries is short okay and
murder is just saying he's just having
fun which is true it seems like that no
it's and it is it's we can all agree I
think that this is the best we've seen
just two beer in a very long time yeah